[Music]
55 on your friday morning what's driving
you crazy well we got to push to the
finish line underway where the 95 meets
the 215 northern beltway come on let's
go
[Music]
centennial bowling
yeah the final phase of that project is
highlighted by three
new freeway connections
the south 95 to the west 215
the west 215 to the north 95
and then third the east 215 to the north
95.
and while it's not technically
considered a freeway connection i think
it's pretty big deal and actually
kind of cool to connect the east and
west sides of the 95
not using a freeway with these brand new
connections
you'll be able to get to and from oso
blanca on the west
and sky point on the east from either
north or
south of the beltway yeah and next week
we're gonna go over the individual plans
for both oso blanca and skypoint and
we'll also have more on that trail that
planned for the area we mentioned that a
few weeks ago but
don't expect any of this to happen right
away ndot says this 155 million dollar
part of the centennial bowl is scheduled
for completion
in early 2024.
all this information is on our website
eightnewsnow.com you click traffic than
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully and put down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
the email is traffic 8
at 8newsnow.com